I'm Matt Susskind and for this game we
are a team of eight people working on
forecast based financing which is a
technique of using forecast in order to
make decisions about what to do in
response to incoming disasters currently
a lot of techniques are we're going to
build long-term protection for cities in
terms of dams or disaster preparedness
or after disaster happens we will react
to the disaster but there's not a lot of
work done in terms of we see that there
is a 50% chance of disaster within the
next week let's start mobilizing to
prepare for that and part of the reason
for that is because if the disaster
doesn't happen you end up wasting money
but if you actually do an analysis
you'll realize that the money that you
waste is actually way less expensive
than trying to make up for your lack of
preparedness after the fact
so Paulo had come in from the red claw
Red Cross Red Crescent Climate Center
and he pitched a couple of different
concepts that they wanted games around
in order to educate either members of
the Red Cross or people out in the world
who they wanted to show these different
ideas to and so what he showed us was
actually just a PowerPoint with a couple
of different slides were on each slide
was a different concept ours was
forecast based financing but then they
were also ones like cholera or Ebola or
preparing for heat waves things like
that and so he gave us a quick pitch of
this is what the concept is this is who
we want to educate with this and these
are some of the characteristics that we
think are really important and we
actually we weren't assigned to any
topics he put those topics up on the
board and let teams form around them
depending on what you're interested in
and so beyond just the idea of this is
forecast based financing and this is how
it works and who we want to teach it to
we got no further instructions Pablo did
come in throughout the class to teach us
a little bit more about who would be
talking to or to work over the ideas
that we had been exploring but on the
whole we just got the general topic and
came up with the game ideas on our own
one of our biggest challenges was with
forecast-based financing it's an
understandable topic but it's sort of
abstract and it doesn't quite lend
itself to a game it's very easy to come
up with we're going to take forecast
based financing and like hide it as a
game but that's not a fun game to play
so a lot of our challenge was figuring
out how are we going to work hard how
are we going to create a game around
forecast based financing that explains
the ideas that we want that teaches
people something new and is a game that
we're actually proud of another
compounding factor was that originally
our target audience was policy makers
which was a very difficult audience
because they don't generally play games
which meant that we are starting with
trying to teach them everything from
scratch whereas when you're creating for
somebody who has experience with video
games you can take a lot of things for
granted that they're gonna know how to
drag-and-drop things in order to change
things or what they the various sort of
design ideas you're using actually mean
to them so that was a big challenge for
us was designing for this new new
consumer and we also had a lot of design
challenges with getting the forecast
based financing game to work and the way
that we approached it at first was by
creating a whole bunch of different
prototypes of a lot of different types
of games and find them out with people
seeing what they understood what they
liked about them what didn't work what
they learn from them which was really
good in terms of exploring different
ideas and learning more about the the
subject area but it created a new
difficulty and that we were all over the
place for the first couple weeks of the
project we got to the point about half
way through we had about eight weeks to
do this project I think and halfway
through we still didn't end up with our
final idea yet instead we were exploring
all these different ideas and pulling
various parts of them in order to make
our game and then we realized that our
game lacked a coherent vision we had
been working on a couple prototypes we
didn't like any of them
it didn't feel like players had a
connection to them both in terms of you
know what was happening in the game but
also a mental connection of I understand
exactly what's happening here so we
decided to take everything we had
learned and some of the systems we had
built and packaged them into sort of a
new UI which was the side view of the
rising water which everybody just
understood intuitively you see a village
you see someone standing there and you
see the water rising toward it and it
doesn't matter who you are you
understand that this is something that's
in danger and you're going to need to do
something about the rising waters
and once we hit on that idea everything
became much easier of course they were
still ideas we had to explain concepts
we had to design into the game in an
understandable way but for the most part
the the game was actually there
the mechanics themselves didn't change
very much between the prototype we had
before and this idea of the rising
waters but just packaging it in a new
design change the game the feel of it
completely
so I
game design experience beforehand so I
came in I like game design a lot I was
hoping to work more on that but also to
get some interesting games made I think
I did get some of that but probably the
thing I learned the most that I didn't
expect coming in was just how to work
with a team we're all busy MIT students
and so we would have weeks where all of
a sudden everybody would have a test and
we could just like do we had no time to
do anything else and so it was a lot of
learning how to work with people who are
extremely busy and who have a lot on
their plate and so it's really easy for
things to slip or things to get
forgotten fall through the cracks
so it taught me a lot about about
project management basically and and
solving problems as a team and learning
how to get everybody I don't want to say
herding cats cuz it's not like people
didn't care but it's just that we were
so busy it taught me how to work with
these kind of busy people to get to
where we needed to be